it's called plasticity
again from chapter 9 childhood chapter
of a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
childhood
excuse me hold on
childhood and by extension parenting is
an interplay of love and release of
holding someone close while also giving
them freedom to explore even perhaps to
leave
in biology we speak of plasticity often
phenotypic plasticity to refer to the
many outcomes that are possible from the
same starting materials
roughly speaking a genotype say the
alleles for brown eyes produces a
phenotype the actual brown eyes
phenotype is the observable form of an
organism for many traits though a
particular genotype encodes information
for a range of possible phenotypes and
interactions with the molecular cellular
gestational and external environment
determine what phenotype will actually
be produced
phenotypic plasticity allows individuals
to respond in real time to changing
environments to avoid being catalyzed
into set patterns and life ways by their
genes
the skulls of dominant wild hyenas are
big and robust with large sagittal
crests on top and broad zygomatic arches
of their cheeks both of these structures
provide places for muscles to attach
much needed if you're in the business of
asserting your dominance with your teeth
compare this to the skulls of hyenas
born and raised in captivity which have
no such structures
the different environments of wild
versus captive hyenas affect what form
or morph they have
in the same vein human children who
choose soft processed foods have smaller
faces as adults than those who grew up
chewing hard tough food
spadefoot tadpoles can grow slowly into
omnivorous morphs or if they are tightly
packed and running out of time and space
in the ephemeral pools in which they
live they can grow more quickly into
larger fiercer cannibal morphs and feed
on each other
what morph a spadefoot tadpole develops
into is entirely context dependent
when temperatures soar zebra finches
communicate this to their unhatched
chicks
zebra finch chicks whose parents told
them about high temperatures while they
were still on their eggs alter their
begging behavior as nestlings and when
they become adults they prefer harder
nest sites
even our critically important aortic
arch the first arterial branch off the
heart that takes oxygenated blood to the
body has several common anatomies within
human populations which can develop from
highly similar genetic starting gates
plasticity provides the possibility of
alternate phenotypes often through
simple rules that do not prescribe
precise outcomes the result ever more so
with increasing levels of complexity is
exploration of new territory literal and
metaphorical
one place that plasticity manifests in
humans is the wide variety of approaches
to parenting across cultures
in tajikistan babies and toddlers are
restrained for hours on end in cradles
known as gevoras
gavoras are treasured within families
and passed down between generations
tajik children are the center of family
life mothers grandmothers aunts and
neighbors are always available and
immediately respond to cries from a
cradle baby with food singing or other
comfort
counter to western expectations though
within a few weeks of babies being born
they are placed in gevorah's provided
funnels and holes through which to pee
and poop and their legs and torsos are
tightly bound
children thus cradled can move their
heads but little else
these children with little experience
crawling or attempting to walk in their
infancy do not walk as early as children
raised in the west
the world health organization's formal
expectations for when children started
to walk are between 8 and 18 months and
yet tajik children may not walk until 2
or 3 years of age
are the tajik babies dullards or
physically incompetent
no
in contrast
children in a rural kenyan village sit
and walk earlier than western babies
tend to
are the kenyan babies inherently
designed for greatness their precocious
motor skills predictive of early mastery
across domains
also now
variations in baby raising culture
across humans exemplify some of the
great plasticity that humans have
kenyan babies walk earlier than western
babies but all but the most severely
disabled western babies learn to walk
soon enough
weird parents are not just focused on
our children we are focused on the
metrics that are easily recorded and
conveyed to others the when of our
child's first smile word or step
once we have such metrics in hand we are
easily confused into imagining that the
when is a critical measure not just of
health but a future capacity
once again the easily measured thing the
calorie the size the date becomes an
inaccurate stand-in for a larger
analysis of the health of the system
by believing the false notion that when
a benchmark is met is the salient
measure of health and progress we play
into our modern fear of risk it is risky
for my child to miss a benchmark it is
risky for me not to force my child to
meet arbitrary deadlines such parental
focus can instill fear in our children
which they carry forward as an aversion
to risk
so important
if you don't learn to manage risk as a
child you won't be able to manage it as
an adult and you're very likely to
run afoul of the
full adult scale hazards yeah and so
maybe that's um
that then
unless you had something right away is a
good way to segue into talking about
america's worst mom
wow i know she's a friend of ours you
know
i didn't yeah
lenore skinesi
wow oh right mom yep yep so for those of
you who don't know um sure the second
edition of her book free range kids is
just out and it's fabulous
um
except wait what what business does she
have talking about childhood she's
america's worst mom yes how'd she get
that description what her earned her
that delightful title in 2008 so she's a
new yorker she lives in new york city um
in 2008 she let her then nine-year-old
son find his way home alone on the new
york city subway he had been begging her
to let him do it
she did
from the article that she wrote which
we'll post in the show notes on the new
york sun quote long story short my son
got home ecstatic with independence
but of course the uproar was immediate
and fierce how could she have let her
precious cargo loose in the
terrible hostile environment that is the
a modern american city
and you know in part her position is
the city is supposedly safer than it's
been since the 60s like you know we've
we've gotten better but you know more to
the point
the the safetyism which is something
that she talks about and jonathan height
talks about and indeed the two of them
together along with um an excellent
psychologist named peter gray and also
daniel shukman
former chairman of fire started an
organization called let grow which is
specifically about creating children who
enjoy risk and have independence and are
anti-fragile
and
lenore who's a friend of ours
is an advocate for safe and independent
um childhood responsibility
and
just think about in light of i'll show
this later but in light of that story
about what's going on in tajikistan and
what's going on in a rural kenyan
village
the the variety of approaches to
parenthood in functioning cultures you
know we're not talking about outliers
and psychopaths within cultures who are
abusers and frankly evil that's not who
we're talking about we're talking about
other cultures in which children
grow up to be adults who are functioning
unproductive
that do things so differently from how
we do them and yet when american adults
stray from you know where when weird you
know when western educated uh
industrialized rich democratic
um
people in in countries that that that
describes do things that go outside of
the current mores of safetyism and
protectionism and
always looking over the shoulder of
children and informing them what they
should do and telling them what the
rules are and making sure they don't
stray
when when we go outside of that we are
told that we're putting our children at
risk
and you know this
this requires a bigger conversation
about risk which we will i think start
today and i mean we've been talking
about but uh maybe
we will be talking about for for some
time but
the idea that individual level risk is
the only risk that should be thought
about and that should be um
should be responded to
because it's the easiest to measure as
opposed to creating a society of people
who are incapable of doing the analytics
themselves and taking and taking
responsibility for their own risks such
that you then have a society level
problem a society level pathology really
in which people aren't capable of
figuring out what is true for themselves
well i do think
in the interest of balance we should
point out that there is some evidence
that a relaxed parenting style can lead
to moderate to severe cases of
heterodoxy
and you know there's no telling where
that goes but
um
yeah so the other thing is in some sense
i mean here's the really uncomfortable
part of this
there is no there's literally no way to
raise your children so that they are
safe and are capable of managing risk as
adults the way you learn to manage risk
is through things not going completely
well and adjusting right yeah you you
manage risk you
take all risk out of a childhood and you
end up with a person in an 18 year old
body with the brain of a child and how
is it that they're going to continue
like how is it they're going to become
adults it's ever harder plasticity does
get less and less acute the longer you
go you you develop right
in fact what you will get is colleges
full of children demanding that the
world be made safe around them right
right which you know i know that sounds
far-fetched but it could happen yeah um
but so in some sense what we're saying
is
that um
if you keep your kids
safe that you are putting the adults
they will grow into at risk right that's
the counterintuitive point right well
and but not just that if you keep your
children safe you're putting the adults
that they will grow into at risk they
will be less competent less productive
more fragile
less capable in all realms
and furthermore and some parents will
say not my responsibility but
furthermore you are putting the society
into which you are moving them at great
risk
so you are also taking you are also
creating a cost that all of us bear
um by creating fragile children
and are they
do they have a higher chance of
surviving to their 18th birthday if you
put them in a bubble for those first 18
years yes they do is that 18 year old
someone who is going to surprise you
going to be creative going to be
productive going to be analytically
insightful going to be industrious going
to be capable
no
no but they're going to be alive
so you know which which of these things
do
do
do you treasure more obviously we want
our children to be alive
but at the cost of everything else
everything else
a guarantee
almost a guarantee that by bubbling them
up for the first 18 years they will
survive and then let then you have a
perennial child and then you have a
society full of perennial children right
and you know i think many of us have
happened on
this
realization from different paths yeah i
mean this is not so different i mean
it's not at all different really from
jordan peterson suggesting that you not
interrupt children while they're
skateboarding sure right it's the same
thing and the point is is skateboarding
safe
nope but it is a good way to break your
arm
and learn the lesson of how one breaks
their arm while you're young yeah and is
this safe zac you want to show this
right
so for those listening this is a picture
of our then are then eight-year-old son
toby
uh jumping off the fallen excuse me uh
the root mass of a of a big leaf maple
that had fallen in an ice storm the year
or two before um it's it's quite a ways
down and he's jumping into a mixture of
salah and oregon grape mostly not oregon
grape although i see some of it there or
i can grape being somewhat spiny um and
he did it over and over and over again
and so did the dog and so did zach and
this just as the picture that i i found
you know is could he break a leg he
could
could he break his skull open
he could this isn't where you start
you don't start by jumping off the
highest thing into an uneven surface you
learn to fall
you you figure out how to deal with your
environment in small steps such that by
the time
you're eight you can do this and by the
time you're 18 you can do more yeah
and you know in fact we are of course
wired for these things um i have
hypothesized that we have many
weird characteristics uh
lowercase weird not weird country
characteristics but weird
characteristics designed to train us to
protect things that matter
right and my guess the prediction of the
model is that um you get hit in the
testicles more when you're young
right and that i didn't no
i'm sure you didn't but those of us who
did
right it's a very profound experience
and the point is anything that you do
that results in a likelihood of that
leaves a very clear imprint on you and
it trains you without anybody having to
wag a finger right you you understand
exactly what the problem is and you just
learn not to get hit in the nuts and
yeah i mean it's the difference between
knowledge gained by embodiment and
experience as opposed to being told you
know like dude play better tennis
cool done okay if it were that easy
which it's not and somehow in this
incredibly abstract
unfortunately far too post-modern world
in which so many of the people engaging
even those who say they've they've seen
the flaws of post-modernism and are not
going to engage in any more so many
people are operating an entirely social
landscape like making arguments that are
about sociality as oppo about social
implications and what other people say
whether people think as opposed to what
is true like what what actually is true
and the way you know that best is by
physically engaging the truth of
whatever it is that you're trying to
physically engage well i do think
physically is the way you learn all
these basic lessons and then there's a
way to extrapolate so you can learn
lessons that you can't possibly afford
to learn yourself which i know it's
become a joke in our family but um i am
quite a big fan of the subreddit what
could go wrong
because a lot of things can go wrong and
the most interesting things on what
could go wrong are the things that go
wrong repeatedly that you don't think
are likely to happen at all right those
are very fascinating things and um
anyway it does cause
so so the point and bonus you get ads
for divorce lawyers when you're looking
at what could go wrong
actually i did not i did not think about
whether or not i was browsing what could
go wrong when the divorce lawyer ad came
up but um
but anyway yes
there's a bunch of stuff you can learn
yourself and nobody has to tell you hey
don't get hit in the nuts again right
don't get hit in the nuts again nobody
needs to say it right also hey
try nothing you don't need school for
right try not to hit your funny bone
yeah got it all right right there's a
very good reason you know most people
don't realize that there's a good reason
for the funny bone thing and it has to
do with what happens to the nerves that
operate your very important hands as
they pass through a joint that can't
allow those nerves to be protected by
all the outer stuff and so
you know bumping your funny bone is a
warning hey if you keep doing that
you're going to lose use of your hand
yeah right so anyway
um
if you insulate your children from the
things that will cause them to get hit
in the nuts they might get hit in the
nuts as an adult which is a bad thing
[Music]